en fait bon je passe comme j'avais dit
au
mtre ça s'est passé quand vous souvenez
pouvez me le dire ça commencé quand quel
âge environ pour
vousen sais rien 3 ans je pense 3 ans à
peu
près et ça a duré jusqu'à quand en gros
ça
peutêre com dire oui tout petit je
rêvais d'aider les autres sauver
secourir
j'ai des menaces de
mort j'ai qué le
quartier finalement j'ai changé de cap
je suis journaliste et j'ai décidé
d'aller à la rencontre de ces hommes et
de ces femmes ordinaires qui exercent
des métiers hors du
commun quand l' vu on est monté à la
maison après il nous il nous a couré
avec son en l'air me voilà mulouse dans
ce qu'on appelait autrefois une brigade
des mineurs et qu'on nomme aujourd'hui
unité de protection sociale se policiers
qui luttent au quotidien contre la
pédophilie le viol la prostitution et la
maltraitance des
[Musique]
mineurs je pense qu'il est M Yannick
l'ancêtre du service 13 ans de brigade
au
compteur c'est jamais marrant de toute
manière d'enlever un gamin à ses parents
autant pour le gamin que pour les
parents
Jérôme a rejoint l'équipe après
plusieurs années à la brigade de
nuit il était comme ça le jizi du
monsieur tous travaillent sous les ordre
de Gwenael 36 ans
capitaine pendant une semaine je vais
plonger dans leur
univers je sais pas je sais pas on va
rentrer chez madame d'accord c'est la
police c'est la police vous inquiétez
[Musique]
pas
mous est la deè agglomération d'Alsace
[Musique]
habitants nous sommes lundi c'est mon
premier jour au sein de
[Musique]
l'unité il est à peine 9h et dans le
bureau de
Gwennael la semaine commence en douceur
par une affaire
d'exhibitionnisme il était caché sur le
côté d'accord et mes enfants mes filles
elles courent toujours devant moi j'ai
toujours devant moi elles sont mis à
courir et au même moment il est sorti
avec son sex salaire quoi pas pris plus
apparemment l'HME est
récidiviste et n'est pas la première
fois qu'il re près de cette cité HLM
avec la vilain
[Musique]
manie jours ila
fait FO espace de 15 jours quoi
c'est le manè aurait pu durer encore
longtemps mais cette maman excédé a
décidé de porter
PL commencequiant quand mêmeoi mais pas
tu as que devant les enfantsentends bien
que devant les
[Musique]
enfants il faut interroger les jeunes
témoins
Enel sait faire ça il sait décrypter les
mots des
enfants tinstalles ici tu t'asseoir
[Musique]
parfait la première petite fille à
témoigner très
jeune ireon a précision ce a vu sans
heurter tu l'as
V j'ai vu après il y avait dit à ma
grandur qui est passé devant après avec
ma copine après avec moi et moi et nous
quand il nous a vu en fait maman elle
était derrière nous quand il nous a vu
il a mon après quand il a vu ma mère il
a dit j'étais juste en train de
pisser
coup de chance pour le capitaine la
gamine n'a pas la langue dans sa
poche des qui l'avait vu j'étais en bas
dans la cour avec mon
cousin et après après il est
arrivé il nous a coursé dans les
escaliers parce que nous en fait parce
que quand l' vu on est monté à la maison
après il nous a coursé avec son en
l'air
je réalise que l'affaire est peut-être
plus sérieuse qu'elle n'y paraissait au
premier abord non seulement cet homme
s'exhibe mais il le fait devant des
enfants est-ce qu'il te disait quelque
chose quand il te
coursait
rien d'accord alors tu as vu son Ziz tu
me dis comment comment comment comment
ça se fait que tu as vu sonizce que il a
montré après il a dit à ma maman qu'il
voulait faire pipi d'accord et c'était
même pas vrai et comment il a fait pour
montrer son
il a juste baissé son zizi il a tourné
vers nous d'accord ça il l'a fait devant
toi devant moi devant ma copine et
devant ma sœur en moins de 15 minutes
gwenel sait tout absolument tout sur le
zizi du
monsieur en revanche dans le bureau d'à
côté Jérôme est à la peine et pourquoi
est-ce que tu sais pourquoi il s'est mis
face à vous est-ce qu' comment ça se
fait à quel moment à le quand quand
arriv d'accord quand vous arriviez il y
avait des autres gens là il faut dire
que la plus petite des TR sœur est un
petit bout de chou vous êtes arriv et
même pour un professionnel comme Jérôme
interroger une si petite fille c'est la
vol mais il faisait pipi où d'après toi
il y avait quoi un mur avait un
arbre il fais PIP où il y avait un arbre
il était près d'un
arbre d'accord il y avait des bars des
bars comment ça des bar il avait des bar
et puis après la était juste derrière
lui d'accord
ok estce que tu as vu autre chose encore
non person d'cord que lui
d'accord Jér pense qu'il en sait
assz je vais te laisser tranquille alors
allez viens jeompagne
là
paradoxalement c'est l'aîné des trois
filles qui a le plus de mal à s'exprimer
elle a la pudeur des
préadoieur il ressembl à quoi la chose
du
garçon je sais pas comment dire je sais
pas comment le dire non je sais pas
commentel comprend vite que l'enfant est
gêné il décide de lui venir en aide si
je te alors attends si je te montre
quelque chose on va regarder il lui
montre une poupée spécialement conçue
pour ce type
d'interrogatoire est-ce que on peut
utiliser ça d'accord alors ce qu'on va
faire regarde ça comme
ça est-ce que tu peux me montrer
làdessus comment il est du monsieur
est-ce que ça tu peux me montrer ce que
veut savoir le jeune capitaine c'est si
l'homme était en
éretion signe que les enfants l'excitent
avec un risque de passer à
l'acte monsieur il était
comment par rapport à
ça est-ce qu'il était comme est-ce qu'il
était comme la la
poupée ça il était comme ça le du
monsieur d'accord en désignant naïvement
le bras de la poupé l'enfant vient de
donner à l'enquêteur l'information qu'il
cherchait à
obtenir est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il
est-ce qu'il faisit quelque chose avec
sa main
monsieur non
le zizil est-ce qu'il tenait son zizil
Monsieur Je poser la question un peu
plus directement non il tenait pas son
zizi d'accord ok c'est quoi la technique
pour intervie un petit enfant comme ça
j'ai vu qu'au début tu commences par
leur demander quel âge elles ont où
elles habit bien à l'école voilà je
pense qu'il est important de les mettre
à l'aise déjà et puis de tester aussi un
petit peu
leur leur langage leur facilité à
répondre aux questions c'est important
de voir si si elle est à l'aise pour
dire son âge sa classe un enfant déjà
qui va bien parler quo elles sont même
brillantes elle est même brillante cette
elle est brillante tout
fait lors de leur déposition les petites
filles ont indiqué aux enquêteurs que
l'exhibitionniste avait une cicatrice or
le récidiviste auquel toute l'équipe
pense porte une cicatrice il est temps
d'aller chez
lui d'après les informations des
policiers le suspect vit dans cet
immeuble d'un quartier c'est populaire
de la
ville chez ses parents d'ailleurs c'est
sa mère qui nous ouvre la
porte on va rentrer il est ici ou pas je
sais pas je sais vous savez pas on va
rentrer chez vous madame d'accord c'est
la police c'est la police vous inquiétez
pas au début la famille prétend qu'il
n'est pas
là c'est quoi ça c'est quoi là comme
pièce mais les policiers ne sont pas
dupes Yassine vous ouvrez s'il vous
plaît écoutez là je suis sous la douche
monsieur
ouais ben vous ouvrez vous sortez tout
de suite là je je en train de m'abiller
l'homme met du temps à s'habiller
beaucoup trop au goût de Jérôme qui
commence à perdre
patience vous pouvez me laisser au moins
toutz-vous on est obligé de rester là
attendez ça vous dérange pas de montrer
votre [__] à tout le monde c'est pas dem
vous allez nous la faire
hein lui il a pas l'air d'être très
surpris hein il a l'air de il
s'attendait un peu à ça
quoi
ilut Pasu après quelques minutes de pour
parler le jeune homme finit par nous
suivre dans le calme il faut dire qu'il
a déjà été condamné C fois pour
exhibition les visites à la brigade il
en a
l'habitude en fait moi je la trouve
super intéressante cette affaire parce
que ce genre de type là ils sont assez
inoffensifs a priori même si quand même
se masturber avec éjaculation devant des
enfants c'est pas banal mais la plupart
des des grands violeurs des grands
pédophiles qui passent à l'action et des
grands tueurs de l'histoire récente du
crime ont tous commencé par des
exhibitions c'estàdire c'est le stade
premier ça veut pas dire que tous les
exhibitionnistes deviennent des grands
tueurs mais enfin tous les grands tueurs
et les grands violeurs les grands
pédophiles ont commencer par des
exhibitions donc c'est un truc
évidemment le système doit absolument
pas prendre à la léchè
après sa garde à vue l'homme a été jugé
en comparution
[Musique]
immédiate il a été condamné à 1 an de
prison ferme et 15000 €
d'amende vous souhaitez un examen
médical est-ce que vous souhaitez
l'assistance d'un avocat ben si ça va
plus loin oui
si ça va plus loin il est 9h c'est mon
deuxè jour à la
brigade ce matin Yanni a convoqué un
homme d'une soantaine
d'annéeséléphoneil à condition de rester
discret j'ai le privilège de participer
à un H auquel personne n'assiste
jamaisme esté Deol petite fille de sa
compagne il n'a pas l'air de bien saisir
la gravité de la
situation je vous informe que je vous
place donc en garde-avenue
d'accord compé de ce jour
9h45 selon la jeune fille ses agressions
se seraient déroulé à plusieurs reprises
alors qu'elle était encore une enfant
aujourd'hui elle est majeure il a fallu
longtemps pour qu'elle porte plainte
plus
vous avez le droit de vous entretenir
avec un avocat au début de votre garde à
vue c'estàdire dès maintenant pendant
une demiheure
d'accord c'est à vous de
voir l'avocat oui d'accord vous
connaissez souocofice Ouen pas d'accord
petit à petit l'homme réalise ce qui lui
arrive il est entè libre il ne dormira
pas chez lui ce
soir e passer
là désormais il est en garde à vue pour
24 heur au
moins c'est du temps qui
permet ça dépend des personnes certain
profil de leur faire découvrir un peu le
le côté hospitalier de notre structure
et de lui permettre un dél de réflexion
et de remise en cause donc ça peut
servir ça peut être
utile
[Musique]
mamie alors ouais tu veux la faire euh
non non je la laisse oui bonjour c'est
la police
oui je vous rappelais pour la garde
vue c'est ça
[Musique]
en attendant que le prévenu
s'entretienne avec son avocat sa
compagne la grand-mère de la plignante
est entendu à son tour par
Valérie je vous saz pourquoi vous ce
matin je m'en doutez pas surpris voir
non pas du tout je m'attendais à ça pour
raison parce que ma fille m'avait
prévenu
cette grand-mère a élevé sa petite fille
quand elle était toute
petite sa maman toxicomane en était
incapable de
che bébé elle est sore de l'hôpital éta
chez
moi aujourd'hui le bébé est devenu un
adulte elle accuse le compagnon de sa
grand-mère de l'avoir
viol petite fille explique que
lorsqu'elle était seule avec Jean-Claude
il lui montrait une bête dans une Mle
qu'il fallait caresser doucement pour
qu'elle grandisse j'ai entendu ça vous
en pensez quoi de ça je pense que c'est
pas
vrai absolument pas vrai
c'est ce sont pourant les mots de votre
petite
fille ce sont les mots de votre petite
fille oui parce que c'est c'est sa mère
qui lui a monté la tête pour qu'elle le
Valérie veut savoir si la grand-mère
était au courant un bras de fer vient de
commencer clairement pour vous votre
petit fille raconte des
mensonges tout à
fait donc vous nous dites que est une
menteuse exactement d'accord et que sa
mère est une
menteuse enfinelle se laisse avoir par
sa
mère c'est-à-dire qu'elle qu'elle écoute
sa mère donc c'est une menteteuse quand
même quand elle dit des choses bah oui
oui d'accord oui exactement oui et ça
vous pouvez être sûr que c'est
vrai la vieille dame est persuadée que
sa petite fille est sous l'influence de
sa mère droguée criblé de dette et qui
aurait voulu faire chanter son compagnon
elle voulait une certain somme et si
on si on ne paye
pas dénoncer quoi
comme comme Jean-Claude qui qui a eu des
attouchements sur ma petite fille ce que
cette femme n'arrive pas à admettre
c'est que la plainte émane de sa petite
fille et seulement
d'elle je vous dis que fait une démarche
en son nom propre ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas une démarche de la maman donc de
votre fils qui fait cette démarche
d'accord ça ça m'étonne que c'est qui
fait la démarche
elle en n'est pas capable elle a pas le
courage on dirait que la grand-mère se
sent trahie par sa petite
[Musique]
fille c'est là que la policière abat une
nouvelle carte
bon ça c'est des petits dessins que
votre petite fille elle a fait quand
elle avait 5 ans
vous avz
vu a tellement fait que je pourrais plus
dire à l'époque des la mère de la
fillette à la dérive n'avait pas osé
porter
plainte mais elle avait conservé les
dessins elle a bien fait c'est
quoiès ça peutre quoi
ça pén ça pouroi
pas
alors vous avez une explication ou pas
non jenis
pas à un moment Valérie pense avoir le
dernier mot mais la grand-mère est dans
le
dénis peut-être qu'elle en a vu un sans
savoir que ça s'appelle un pénis et qui
sa qui dès qu'elle aurait pas vu ça chez
sa mère il la prenait de temps en temps
et qu'elle vivait avec quelquun vous
navez pas l'impression votre rôle de
grand-mère c'est aussi de protégerci
s'est passé quelque chose laissez-moi
finir de parler s'il vous plaît madame
oui d'accord vous ne pensez pas
réfléchissez 2 secondes on n'est pas en
train de de discuter sur votre fille on
va laisser votre fille en dehors de ça
sont pases pén tout ce que vous avez
évoqué d'accord les raisons financière
je vois bien que le policier prend cette
histoire très à cœur j'aimerais que vous
endossiez votre rôle de grand-mère avec
tout ce que ça comme dimension humaine
et affective vous avez une petite fille
qui est quelqu'un de super d'accord
c'est moi qui l'ai entendu
est est-ce qu'elle a peur de vieillir
sans son compagnon ou se sent coupable
de ne rien avoir vu ou de ne rien avoir
dit en tout cas la vieille dame ne lâche
rien j'espère qu'un jour ça sortira la
vérité comme ça vous seriez au moins
vous verrez que sur toute la
ligneur mis son sexe dans la bouche à
votre petite
fille je vulgaire il a jou dans la
bouche de votre
fillee croyez pas que vous étiez pas là
c'est normal parce que vous êtes
amoureuse de Jean-Claude mais à un
moment donné il faut peut-être vous dire
là-dedans que c'est
possible pendant que la grand-mère signe
sa déposition j'essaie de comprendre
pourquoi Yannick semble convaincu que la
gamine a raison et je la sens pas du
tout manipulée par cette mère la
démarche la démarche par exemple de
soutien psychologique qu'elle a fait les
séances qu'elle a fait c'était pas du
tout à l'initiative de la mère c'était
son malettre à elle elle l'a fait elle
fait d'initiative avant avant c'est ça
qu'ène ici et c'est ça qu'il a
cheminement cette démarche qu'ilène ici
la démarche de venir ici elle l'a fait
seul
également ce sont des choses dont elle
s'est confier à ses petits amis pour
expliquer certaines difficultés sexu
d'cord donc il faut quand même oser
parler de ça un petit
amiation par exemple par
exemple Yannick se donne 24 he pour
faire parler le
suspect
il peut péter un câble il peut sortir un
couteau il mon travail fait que monsieur
me donne une version je suis obligé de
vous expliquer ce qu'il a dit de vous
poser les
questions ches bien plus
abom don vous êes accus et qui prent des
REP fix dig très bien on sommeil de bébé
Mme S y a la
prison
ça
[Musique]
soulage à la brigade de protection
sociale les histoires de meurs se
suivent et ne se ressemblent pas
forcément Jérôme enquête lui aussi sur
une affaire de viol mais cette fois la
victime est une femme d'un certain âge
et l'affaire est plus
[Musique]
récente vous inquiétez pas de toute
façon ils peuvent pas vous
voir à l'époque des traces ADN ont été
retrouvé sur un M de cigarette sur les
lieux de
l'agression regardez ce que vous
reconnaissez un des individus et vous me
donz le numéro c'est bon or un homme
correspondant au profil ADN vient d'être
mise en garde à vue dans une affaire de
cambriolage la victime doit donc
l'identifier parmi deux autres
prévenus éventuellement le de en ta mais
pas ch rouge et il avait pas de
moustache à
l'époque mais il lui
ressemble il a une
cicatrice il peuvent pas baisser leur
culotte
non malgré son trouble la plignante a
ciblé le bon
numéro Jérôme n'a plus qu'à préparer son
interrogatoire mais il lui faut un
maximum de biscuits et pour cela il doit
réentendre la
victime je' j'habitais dans un quartier
où il y avait pas mal
de on va dire du bruit avec les jeunes
qui traîaiit et qui qui dilit
et j'essayais toujours de faire un peu
de la
pédagogie et on me l'a fait payer cher
cette femme affirme avoir été violé dans
le hall et dans les caves de son
immeuble en juin 2013 quelqu'un soé à ma
porte faisant passer pour quelqu'un
d'autre j'ai ouvert j
d JIS d ouvrir vouis refermer la porte
déjà le pied ded
elle est persuadée qu'elle a été violé
par
par les jeunes de son quartier
d'ailleurs depuis qu'elle a porté
plainte sa vie est devenue un enfer
oui j'ai des menaces de mort j'ai même
changé de
ville j'ai qué le
quartier Jérôme en a suffisamment
entendu il sent que la victime est
épuisée il est temps de la laisser
tranquille on vous tiendra informé de
toute façon
les suitees de l'enquête
d'accord au revoir
madame selon elle il pourrait
correspondre à un des individus qu'on
avait là en
présence et c'est l'individu que nous
visons dans la procédure donc c'est
plutôt
positif ce que la plignante ignore en
revanche c'est que le prévenu est en
garde à vue depuis 12h dans une affaire
de cambriolage jérô a très peu de temps
pour obtenir des aveux dans ce dossier
de viol au bout de la garde à vue ça
sera trop
[Musique]
tard il est 14h le grand-père accusé de
viol par la petite fille de sa compagne
va être
réentendu comme la loi lu autorise il
sera assisté d'un avocat pendant toute
la durée de l'interrogatoire
à tout à
l'heure cette fois-ci Yannick qui sent
que le vieil homme est sur le point de
craquer me demande de suivre
l'interrogatoire dans le couloir grâce à
une caméra discrète et un micro posé sur
le
bureau est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose avant que je vous pose des
questions à me préciser vous avez
réfléchi à quelque chose quelque chose
qui vous revienne
non non je su désolé
mais la difficulté c'est que les faits
sont très anciens et que la propre mère
de la gamine une toxicomane nous abois a
essayé de faire chanter le vieux
monsieur par écrit ce qui est emmerdant
c'est la lettre de menace quand même de
la de la mer de la gamine quoi de
chantage chantage terin quand même c'est
un bel argument
ouais c'est c'est une PL une toxicoman
c'est vraiment une elle vend sa
fille panier de lentil
quoi cette lettre peut laisser penser
que la mère droguée a pu inventer cette
histoire en instrumentalisant sa fille
pour soutirer de l'argent au vieux
monsieur un complot donc mais a trouvé
une faille détaillezmoi dans ce courrier
où apparaî le fait qu'elleille vous
faire
chanter
moment a marqué si tu veux qu'on
s'arrange entre
nousi c'est c'est
principe la mère est restée évasive dans
sa lettre elle parle d'arrangement sans
plus de précision Yannick va donc
s'engouffrer dans cette ambigué pour
démonter l'argument du
chantage et si simplement c'était des
explications qu'elle souhaitait je vois
pas d'argent làdedans
je vois pas de sollicitation financière
làdedans oui déj ah non il y a rien il y
a pas d'argent làdedans il y a pas
question d'argent je vous avais auss je
l'avais appelé pour savoir
qu'aranger sauf que ça il y a pas de
trace comme par hasard ça
c'est ça ça vous savez me le dire cette
petite phase mais tout le reste vous
savez pas le dire quoi le papier est
ébranlé mais pour l'instant il ne lâche
rien mis en place une espèce de
protocole ludique un jeu un
jeu qui consistait à sortir une sorte de
petit animal de la mal
l'envelopper d'un t-shirt ou d'un
chiffon ou de quelque chose et de faire
caresser ce petit animal au finin qu'il
devienne plus grand de le caresser
doucement vous pensez que ça c'est le
genre de chose qu'on invente on ne sa
pas ah vous ne savz pas c'est le genre
de souvenir qu'on se fabrique ça comme
ça ne savait
[Musique]
pas l'homme continue de
nier le policier utilise un dernier
argument moi je vais être obligé de
faire une
confrontation vous avez vraiment envie
vous commente les dessins qu'on a
récupéré et placé sous c devant vous
qu'elle vous explique ce que ça veut
dire et qui c'est et ce que c'est vous
avez vraiment envie de ça
lui imposer ça
demain
franchement si j'avais fait quoi que ce
soit est-ce que je d'après vous je
pourrais manger en face de ma compagne
j'ai vu plein de gens qui ont fait des
choses bien bien plus abominables que ce
que que ceux dont vous êtes accusé et
qui me prennent des repas à heur fixes
et qui digèrent très bien et qui ont un
sommeil de bébé j'en ai vu assez dans ma
carrière
oui et j'ai vu des gens être comme vous
droit dans leur botes alors que j'avais
au dossier la preuve
matérielle de ce qui é ce qui leur était
reproché même quand on a la preuve on
demande très longtemps aux gens et très
longuement ce qui s'est
passé Yannick n'a aucune preuve et ne
peut compter que sur des
aveux je vous laisse méditer ça mais
est-ce qu'on peut dire que quand même
d'une certaine manière tu as pris un peu
à cœur l'histoire de cette gamine quand
on voit on dit oui quand même un peu
même si tu as an
mais c'est toujours comme ça c'est il
faut croire il faut un petit peu croire
à une victime si on veut si on veut
bosser quoi d'accord
maintenant il faut rester neutre aussi
ouais faut rester à charge et à décharge
ouais le rôle de l'enquête il est quand
même plutôt un petit peu à charge oui
quand on a un auteur devant soi mais bon
il faut rester quand même sur sur la
retenue un petit peu mais ça te gène pas
de de de te faire un peu et mvoir c'est
fa ouais c'est c'est ça c'est c'est à
dessin d'accord c'est pour l'audition
d'accord mais moi je me suis pas je suis
pas personnellement impacté parce que
sinon j'arrête ouais si je me fais
impacter comme ça j'arrête j'aurais pas
tenu 13 ans d'cord c'est une barjour des
histoires comme ça ah oui mais c'est un
truc oui finir en non non en
psychothérapie ou non non non pas du
tout non non non ou je vais pas ramener
ça ce soir chez moi le policier est un
dur à cuire rest aussi à char si l'homme
ne coopère pas confronté à la jeune
fille même si elle est très fragile mais
bon
d'accord non là on a par contre un gros
souci c'est qu'on a la victime qui est
en bas chez notre psychologue
clinicienne là rattaché et qui fait
March rien qui est complètement effondré
des conséquences je sais ouais je sais
pas ce qui je sais pas exaè au
téléphone comme ça non je sais pas on
prend t les truc je sais pas je te renie
alors que c'est le seul soutien qu'elle
a de sa vie c'est ça grand qu'elle avait
qu'elle av qu'a ou donc je sais pas trop
elle semblit assez forte dans sa dans sa
résolution et je sais pas ce qu'elle est
en train de raconter est-ce qu'elle fait
marche
arrière si la jeune fille se rétracte
avant la fin de la garde à vue yannick a
perdu la partie mais d'expérience il
sait qu'une nuit de cellules attendrait
les plus
[Musique]
coriasses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la brigade de protection sociale
certains jours sont plus douloureux que
d'autres c'est le cas ce matin en tout
cas pour
jérô
2008 2002 ouais d'accord ok 2002 oua
c'est plus grand ça du
coup il est 9h les de hommes s'apêt à
partir sur le terrain la mission ce
matin ce qu'on appelle un placement donc
les aut enfant le plus grand est né en
2002 10 ans qui donc il sera pas là peti
2008 fait 6 ans grosso modo 5 6 ans il y
a encore un petit bébé il y un petit
bébé il y en a plus petitiser les autres
on sait Pasel il s'agit de retirer à sa
famille un enfant jugé en danger les
policiers n'aiment pas ces moments il
ser paséle
ouais ça marche et le papa il travaille
ou pas
ouais je sais pas comment expliquer mais
déjà on enlever des enfants à des
parents en soi c'est c'est compliqué en
plus on va le faire au domicile
donc ils sont chez eux les parents sont
déjà
opposés aux aid parce que quand les
éducateurs viennent à la maison ou
l'istance sociale vient à la maison il
leur ouvre pas la porte alors nous on
est la police ça risque d'être encore
plus
compliqué l'équipe part à reculon
d'autant que ce type de mission peut
très vite
déraper et le pire des situations c'est
si le gamin qu'on doit prendre est dans
le bras d'un dans les bras d'un des
parents parce que ça nous ça nous
empêche carrément d'agir parce que on
peut pas on va pas l'arracher des bras
c'est très stressant comme mission on
préfère se lever à 6h du matin puis
aller chercher un bandit
hein plutôt que d'enlever un
gamin pour éviter les dérapages mieux
vaut être nombreux sur place Jérôme et
Gwel ont besoin de
renfort ou élastique ça va amuser les
gosses Genel a donc fait appel au
collègues de la Sûreté
publique
bonjour ce sont des habitués du risque
qui s'équipent comme pour monter sur un
braquage on sait pas à qui on
aire surtout dans ce type d'événement
en l'urence pre je crois il peut péter
un câble il peut sortir un couteau il
peut ça peut partir en live très vite il
est 9h30 les trois véhicules prennent la
direction d'une cité de
mulouse l'enfant à placé est un petit
garçon issu d'une famille nombreuse il
est déscolarisé depuis plusieurs mois et
présente t de développement
inquiétant quand l'équipe arrive sur
place les assistantes sociales sont déjà
là et ell n'emmènent pas large à
l'intérieur la maman hurle et brise la
vaisselle ça se passe bien madame non ça
passe
[Musique]
pasame Valérie en profite pour s'arer du
petit gar
sieur en moins de 5 minutes l'enfant est
au mains des assistantes sociales mais
la maman revient à la charge et il faut
absolument la
calmerant moi Madame madame vous allez
le voir mais vous allez aller voir très
vite vous avez un droit de visite vous
allez le voir très
rapidement la
maison
[Musique]
l'opération n'aura duré qu'un quart
d'heure mais les policiers en ressortent
avec le
[Musique]
blouses ce matin Yannick doit réentendre
le papi accusé de viol par latite F de
sa
compagne le vieil homme vient de passer
une nuit de 8h en cellule de garde à
[Musique]
vue je pense qu'il est
mur qu'est-ce qui te fait penser
ça les mimiques du visage ouais le
regard baissé il est en train de
réfléchir à ce qu' va à la façon dont il
va me présenter la chose je pense il a
passé la nuit ressenti à gamberger oui
oui voilà voilà
voà ce que j'ai ressenti aussi ouais si
c'est l'habitude ça si on va appeler ça
comme ça oui c'est vrai qu'il a qu'il a
pleuré un peu cette nuit enin que le
jaolier la l'a vu en larme là cette nu
ah c'est possible c'est moi qui l'ai vu
en larme ce matin c'est toi qui l' vu
c'est quand je l'ai quand il sa garde à
vue été prolongée que je l'ai ramené en
jaule il a éclaté en sangloot dans sa
dans sa jaule
d'accord ça c'est la vertu de de la
garde à
vue les policiers sent quand un prévenu
est prêt à
parler dans le cas contraire il faudra
le confronter à la gamine to tu voudrais
qu'ilees devant toi ce matin ou cet
aprs-midi en confrontation alors
humement je préfère que
éviter cette gamine d'être confronté à
ça Yannick va être
fixé l'homme a terminé de s'entretenir
avec son nouvel
avocat je vous réitère votre faculté
donc de me faire des
déclarations dire spontané de répondre à
mes questions ou de vous taire d'accord
dans le cadre de cette procédure
ok on en est à la 3e audition dans ce
dans ce ce dossier qui est bien épais
un dossier où il est avéré que vous avez
pour l'instant menti à plusieurs
reprises
d'accord et de la possibilité je je vous
rappelle qui qui vous est donc là
offerte de lui permettre de construire
sa vie Yannick le sent l'homme est sur
le point de craquer pu c'est aussi une
chance pour vous de faire preuve d'un
tout petit peu ou de beaucoup d'humanité
hein et et de savoir vous montrer vous
montrer responsable je pense qu'à votre
âge vous avez fait votre vie
je vous donne l'opportunité de pas
dégrader votre image plus qu'elle ne
l'est auprès desès et de lui éviter de
lui éviter quelque chose qui pourrait
être très très
douloureux donc je vous
écoute Yannick avait raison après de
auditions 3 heur d'interrogatoire et une
nuit en cellule de garde à vue le papi
craque en fait bon je passe comm j'avais
dit au
mtre yannick a presque gagné la
batailleant mais les aveux ne suffisent
pas pour boucler le dossier il faut des
détails et une
chronologie ça s'est passé quand vous
vous souvenez pouvez me le dire ça a
commencé
quand quel âge environ pour vous j'en
sais rien 3 ans je pense 3 ans à peu
près et ça a duré jusqu'à
quand en gros ça
peutête 4 ans
oui ça confirme ce qu'il savait par
ailleurs les viols ont duré de longues
années
ça se passait où
Monsieur céta tous les
jours non pas tous les
jour dans le couloir le reste de
l'équipe bientôt nouvelle et je
comprends que le service tout entier
prend cette affaire à
cœur vous retiriez pour
jouir vous vous retiriez de sa bouche
pour jouir en général
ou dans le
bureau Yannick entre maintenant dans les
détails expliquez-moi
simplement tout
simplement ben alors disons je je l'
caresser et
voilà à quel vous
l' sur le corp quoi et puis sur le
sex ENF avec le avec la
culotte audessus des vêtements oui
d'acord
ça faire une une faation voilà
comment vous Luz demandé comment vous
Luz présenté
ça
je maintenant Yanni en sa assz si ces
aux sont une réhabilitation pour la
victime c'est aussi une délivrance pour
celui qui fut presque son
grand-père man
ouais ça vous PESIT toutes ces années de
silence
oui même s'il y a de la prison au
bour ça
soulage quand est-ce que vous avez
décidé de parler
cette nuit
l'HE tout à
l'heure et là vous vous sentez
vidé au terme de sa mise en
examen l'homme rentrera chez lui libre
mais placé sous contrôle
judiciaire il risque 20 ans de
prison
tu es content que ça
soit bouclé ben dans le cas présent je
suis surtout content pour la victime on
a une vraie victime qui va être enfin
reconnue qui va pouvoir se reconstruire
avoir une une histoire qui qui a qui est
jeune qui a 20 ans je t'ai entendu dire
tout à l'heure au suivant parce que même
d'ici la fin de cette semaine il est
possible que tu a une autre affaire du
même tonneau et il est possible que tout
à l'heure oui ou et des affaires comme
ça on en a toujours un petit peu en
portefeuille ouais ouais c'est c'est le
quotidien de la brigade oui ou oui
[Musique]
ouais malheureusement ce quotidien n'est
pas fait que de victoire Jérôme suite
une affaire de viol aujourd'hui il
reçoit à nouveau la victime mais il n'a
pas une bonne nouvelle à lui
annoncer voilà je vous en prie esszv ici
l'individu qu'on avait placé en garde à
vue dans le cadre de
l'affaire on a dû le libérer parce que
j'avait d'autres choses encore d'enquête
à faire des actes d'enquête qui
nécessitaent un peu de temps donc pour
pouvoir avoir un maximum de temps il a
été libéré les policiers n'avaient pas
assez d'éléments contre lui ils ont dû
le relâcher après 24 heures de garde à
vue il est pas sur la
même comment dire sur la même version
que vous c'est-à-dire que lui il
explique que cette relation était
consentie il mis toute notion de
contrainte donc il écarte il écarte
toute notion de
viol oh mais
SIG au secours j'en peux
plus si le prévenu avait nié tout
contact avec la victime Jérôme aurais pu
le confondre avec son ADN seulement il a
tout de suite reconnu une relation
sexuelle alors maintenant c'est paroles
contre parole lui il prétend que vous
lui avez fait des avances en le
caressant et en étant tactile avec lui
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
làdessus je sors de là de toute façon je
me
pas pour cette femme ce nouvel
interrogatoire est insoutenable elle a
l'impression que l'enquêteur ne la croit
pas
là je dois vous poser des questions
madame j'ai pas dit que je croyais lui
mais mon travail fait que monsieur me
donne une version je suis obligé de vous
expliquer ce qu'il a dit et de vous
poser les questions jérô a absolument
besoin de nouveaux éléments pour
relancer l'enquête faute de nouveaux
témoignages le parquet risque de classer
cette affaire sans
suite et puis après s'il a menti sur un
point on tire un fil c'est ça et
inversement si elle a menti sur un point
on tire un fil c'est ça exactement et
petit à petit on essaie de voir pour
avoir un
résultat à cette
enquête c'est un dossier qui a une
chance d'aboutir ou vous est parti pour
un
nonlieu là à l'heure
actuelle je peux vraiment pas dire je
peux vraiment pas dire il y a tellement
de choses qui vont rentrer en ligne de
compte le le résultat de la fin de mes
investigations on verra après c'est un
dossier qui sera peut-être pas portter
aux assises même si on parle d'un viol
au départ c'est il y a des fois les fait
sont requalifiés he ils sont
correctionnalisés en violence sexuelle
ça peut il y a beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent se passer mais voilà tout va
dépendre si on reste sur la version de
la victime on parle on parle de viol
donc effectivement ça pourrait être
jugé jusqu'ici l'enquête de voisinage
n'a rien donné personne n'a rien entendu
et faute de nouveaux témoignages le
parquet risque que de classer cette
affaire sans
[Musique]
suite ça fait une semaine que je partage
la vie de ces policiers mais qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait
[Musique]
tenir
c'est mon collègue qui a fait l'audition
et en fait a tout
reconnu il a dit il dit tout ce que vous
avez
dit il est 15h et pour boucler l'affaire
du viol de la gamine les policiers ont
convoqué la victime ils tenaient à lui
annoncer eux-même que le compagnon de sa
grand-mère était passé aux aveux allez
làâchezvous allez-y on est là pour ça
l'histoire fini il a tout reconnu tout
exactement ce que vous avez dit vous
avez encore un lourd travail à faire
derrière maintenant mais le plus gros
estit d'accord on ma tellement traité de
et ben non vous pouvez vraiment vous
considérer comme une victime et tout ce
que vous avez rêvé vos cauchemars
c'était la
réalité il aura fallu de longues années
à cette jeune fille pour trouver le
courage de parler et 24 heur à Yannick
et ses collègues pour obtenir les
confessions de son
violeur ça ve dire V souvenir les bon
aussi
nêche tout ce travail que vous avez fait
pour vous souvenir des choses pas
[Musique]
Tromp désormais la victime a toutes les
cartes pour se reconstruire
elle a toutes sa vie pour
cela
il est temps pour moi de partir vers de
nouveaux horizons demain j'ai
rendez-vous avec d'autres hommes
d'autres femmes au vie peu
ordinaire